important
good afternoon it's the same message as
previously we've again engaged in
Services of the sound engineer Tim and
he has supplied the mics to work well so
that everyone in the room can hear the
mics must be used properly the streaming
is also very dependent upon the proper
use of the microphones
please will members remember to raise a
hand if you wish to speak so that extend
and sort the microphone or mic can be
brought to you by Asha or Tom
please speak directly into the
microphones they are designed for the
speaker to be very close and do not work
if the speaker is not close
the chair requests that you do not stand
when speaking so that you can get as
close to the microphones as possible
Tim will switch off the microphone when
you have finished speaking and one final
one please don't rustle your papers as
the noise can be picked up by nearby
microphones thank you Chad
thank you
thank you before we start uh the proper
part of the proceedings I'm going to ask
councilor Martin Thacker and councilman
Nigel Barker to say a few words
regarding Dorsey Ward who was a
long-standing member within this chamber
thank you councilman
thank you chair
it is with sadness that we learned of
the death of former councilor Dorothy
Ward
she served on North East Derbyshire
Council for a total of 31 years
Dorothy was first elected in 1976 until
1987.
and then returned to the council from
1991 until 2011
representing North Wingfield Central
she was chair of the council from 1997
until 1998.
Dorothy was a Cabinet member with the
remit of supporting the leader to build
an excellent Council
she was also the no-nonsense chair of
the planning committee
Dorothy was a formidable character
she certainly wasn't a shrinking violet
in Council debate
my favorite comeback from Dorothy at a
full council meeting when we were at
Salter gate was
what did Tories know about anything in
your big Posh houses
she clearly hadn't been to thakka Towers
Dorothy did stand for election one last
time in 2011 in pilsley and Morton Ward
but wasn't elected
this was the ward of her close friend
counselor Ann Holmes
when Anne was chair of the council from
2015 until 2016. Dorothy served as her
consort
during their civic year they fundraised
for the MacMillan Cancer Center
it was during those 12 months that I saw
the kind and caring side of Dorothy
the tough facade used to affect as a
member of the council
gave way to a person who was thoughtful
and genuinely interested in how people
were doing
on behalf of the conservative group I
extend sincere sympathies to her family
and friends
Dorothy served the people of Northeast
Derbyshire well
thank you councilor welcome
thank you
well said Martin thank you chair uh yeah
and and thanks for the opportunity to
say a few words about Dorothy because
quite a few people in here won't they
won't remember Dorothy like you say it's
been a while since she's been on the
council or similar to our homes I think
I made a similar speech when uh we were
talking about Anne that Dorothy was it
can be described as a model Community
counselor she and a representative of
that Community if you're instrumental in
establishing the Community Association
in North Wingfield
uh and that on this body chased up uh
the funding to build the new the
original Community Center which we've
gone you know knocked down and rebuilt
but she did a great job with that and
she helped to provide many Community
facilities in that in that building not
least catering for up to 100 people on a
Thursday afternoon cooking dinners and
and stuff uh she will also a store to
the labor party in Wingfield and she
were a member long before uh I was which
is a very long time ago Gary
and she often told me that she would
help deliver leaflets for her dad when
she were eight-year-old uh down around
Waterloo
which I thought were uh were very Grand
until I realized it Rebecca Wingfield
that we're in lower pilsley well never
mind
uh that commitment to the labor party
was recognized when she received an
award for having been a member for over
50 years uh which which she she really
appreciated that and I would like to put
on record my personal thanks to Dorothy
and on behalf of the labor group and The
Wider labor movement uh our thanks to a
and our condolences also to her friends
and family and thank you Martin for your
words thank you
thank you both
I've had time to consider the agenda for
this afternoon and I'm happy to propose
business and intend to take it in that
order
votes as usual will be by roll call but
they will be recorded both on the budget
just a reminder that we are being live
streamed today by YouTube
so we'll move to the first item on the
agenda apologies of absence
yes chair we've received apologies from
councilor Pam windley House of Phillip
wheelhouse
and so Oscar Gomez Rini councilor pass
and Cliff and councilor Betty Hill
are there any fursive apologies yeah
sorry Lee Stone the office
oh and Jackie originated
item two Declarations of Interest I have
a declaration of interest on this one
for the written in tones part of the
agenda
chair just to declare item six Regional
Home section of the report I declare an
interest as a member of the original
board
councilor Wilton
Council Bluff thank you
councilor
yes it's not working very well
yeah
um
I'm declared interest in iPhone 6
being a tenant of the council thank you
and I could see another hand but I can't
see who it is
thank you
councilor Armitage
item six uh attorney
thank you
moving sorry moving on to item three
minutes of the last meeting we now have
the minutes of the meeting held on
Monday the 28th of November
are we happy that they are a correct
record
is there a mover
thank you Council Adele the second up
councilor Cupid thank you
all those in favor
thank you the motion miscarriage thank
you
item four chairs announcements this is
probably the briefest in history it's
just as to remind you of the service on
Sunday the memorial service for our late
Queen I'd like to thank those that have
already responded but you're all very
welcome
and one fun night to look out for which
will be in March which will be the race
night that councilor Digger is
organizing on my behalf so thank you
item four five sorry leaders
announcements
thank you I'll try and keep my remarks
early uh short as well uh just firstly
just to reiterate um our key message on
the cost of living that the council
stands ready to support all of our
residents obviously just contact us if
you or anyone uh you know needs any help
whatsoever and we are we know that there
are still people out there who are
struggling so would ask that all members
uh keep passing that message on uh in
your local communities uh moving on just
to the leveling up fund bid members will
be aware that we submitted a bid for
17.8 million from the government and
around two of the leveling up fund with
an ambitious master plan to elevate
eckington as the bid was called
unfortunately we were unsuccessful in
the bid and naturally we are
disappointed but we do have to recognize
that we Face some pretty stiff
competition of around 9 billion pounds
worth of bids for a 2 billion uh funding
part we also recognize that we have done
pretty well in terms of attracting
government investment in the past three
or so years having secured a over 30
million pounds to improve Town centers
make Council housing warmer and Greener
improve the Energy Efficiency of our
Leisure centers and make lasting
improvements to several of our
communities under the UK SPF scheme I
think it's also important to highlight
that the background work that we've done
in terms of producing a master plan for
Effington will not go to waste we will
continue to lobby for funding and we'll
be applying again taking into account
the feedback that we received on the on
the original bid and we are in an
infinitely greater position than we were
before now that we do have a clear
vision and a master plan for how accent
could benefit from leveling up so we
will keep banging the drum and keep
working to ensure that eckington does
benefit from that important funding
we're also committed to working with
eckington Parish Council to progress the
plans for a destination park at Lansbury
which was part of the bid and we've
allocated 200 000 to make this ambition
a reality regardless of the outcome of
any future funding bids on the same
subject I'm pleased to inform members
that we are now open for round two of
funding from the UK share Prosperity
quality parks and play areas scheme all
Parish councils are able to apply and
I'm delighted that we were able to award
funding to several projects in round one
uh the district council is also
committed to investing in several parks
that we have responsibility for around
the district as well and on UK share
Prosperity fund we're also open for
applications for our enhancing Village
halls and Community buildings scheme
where operators can apply for up to ten
thousand pounds for refurbishments uh
particularly where the project includes
energy saving measures and so the
deadline for these applications is the
10th of February
um clearly we'll be discussing the
budget and the challenges for our
residents uh shortly but one bit of good
news is that we've decided to freeze our
Leisure Center to membership fees I
think that demonstrates our commitment
to supporting our Leisure service which
is facing Financial challenges due to
Rising Energy prices having invested
heavily improvements to our Senators but
we're also supporting more residents to
access the health and well-being
benefits of membership by keeping our
fees as low as possible at a time when
people are under significant pressures
and finally there's been some what I
feel is unfounded criticism of our
hard-working Street Scene and
environmental health officers recently
so I just wanted to give them a bit of a
shout out and highlight some of the
excellent work that they've been doing
recently we're continuing to have a high
profile prosecutions with a zero
tolerance policy on littering invited
being and this includes a resident in
drumfield recently being fined 300
pounds earlier this month for flight
tipping in eckington we've invested in
expanding our Environmental Health
Service and it's it's reaping rewards so
last year we carried out the most
patrols and they've handed out the most
fixed penalties on record and as a
result fire shipping reports are down 20
compared to 2019 so I just want to thank
the environment Environmental Health
Service in particular and the street
scene service for all of their hard work
uh in recent years to try and really get
tough on that issue thank you very much
thank you
we move on to item six the medium-term
financial plan 2022 23 to 2026-27
as in previous years we will consider
the financial and general fund first and
then the housing revenue account I and
other Rick yield home board members will
withdraw from the meeting at that point
but not before the council has appointed
someone to chair the meeting for the
remainder of that item
first things first I would like to the
Director of Finance and resources change
ethic to give us the presentation on the
plan
I would allow questions to on any
technical points which need
clarification at the end of the
presentation thank you
thank you chair can everybody hear me
yep yep get a bit closer okay good
afternoon everybody
um it's been a difficult year this year
to set the budget as I'm sure you can
all imagine he's been an awful lot of
challenges because I've got my high
heels on the bus better thank you
there's been an awful lot of challenge
as far as this year so um
so I just wanted to spend just a few
minutes before the the budget's gone
through by the portfolio holder just
talking you through some of the
experiences that we've been setting it
this year I'll try not to move my head
too much because if I moved my head too
much it makes a horrible sound
next slide please Janet
thank you okay so I just want to spend a
couple of seconds talking about the
Outlook
um you'll all realize the economic and
fiscal Outlook has been been
unprecedented over the next few years at
the few months since March 2022 it's
been particularly severe
um we're experiencing High inflation and
Rising interest rates and they've all
led to have them forecast Pace
settlements um for the council last year
it averaged seven percent would actually
got two percent which was the average
prior to that in the budget
um significant increases to energy costs
and increases to contractual spending
particularly around our CPT contracts so
we're seeing anything in the region of
15 20 on those contracts
next likely Janet oh she's already done
it she's so good okay just spend a
couple of minutes talking about the
national settlement so in terms of the
national settlement
um it's a further rollover this year so
2019-20 was the last time that we had a
spending review of any substance so
what's been happening since 2019-20s
we've just been rolling over the budgets
and this year is no exception and my
understanding is from the Intel from
from the government is it will be the
same for the next two years so all the
funding reforms have now been delayed
until 2025 which is after the next
general election what that does is it
gives us some certainty for the next two
years but it gives us a lot less
certainty for the second two years of
the plan
next slide thanks Janet
um included in the settlement is new
homes bonus again so I've included that
into the budget for 23 and 24 23 24 and
24 25 and the same applies to the
services Grant which we've got for
another two years the lower tier
Services grant that we had last year has
been replaced by a three percent funding
guarantee but in terms of the detail
when you get into the detail of those
and you sad like me and you calculate
all the numbers they're pretty much
amount to the same sort of thing so
that's in for the next two years as well
that total is just short of a million
pound that we've included in the budget
onto business rates pretty much business
as usual with business rates so we
remain in the Derbyshire pool and the
current growth is based on our forecasts
on that basis There's No Business rates
reset until the 2025 reforms so we've
budgeted on that basis
okay this is an interesting one this
year so assumptions are normally pretty
straightforward but um they've been
incredibly challenging for us this year
um government grants will be included
for the next two years because that's
the assurance that we've been given and
business groups I've just talked about
pay inflations traditionally been around
about the two percent
um last year was Seven next year we've
posted four percent in the budgets we've
built four percent in on the basis that
we're expecting average inflation to be
around the seven between upper Branch
seven percent average so 11 at the
beginning of the year four percent to
the end of the year
um we've got two percent in there after
as we're expecting the markets over the
medium term to turn to some sort of
normality we're putting some vacancy
efficiencies into the budget as well and
energy costs we're going to track data
on these on a longer basis it's been
incredibly difficult to forecast those
um we have paired them down a little bit
in later years but
um compared to this year and next year
but um incredibly difficult and that one
is going to need some some resolution as
the years progress
so in terms of 23 24
um the shortfall is 977 000 pounds
that's before council tax
um and that's proposed in the report
that you will all be debating later the
budgets are cash limited as they have
been in the past and just to give you an
idea of the flavor of what we've been
including in the budget this year
um energy costs a million pound of pay
inflation a million pound on what we had
in the 22-23 base that you approved this
time last year significant increases
largely well fully out of our control as
well so it's been quite difficult to
plan for government government grants
received as I said earlier is a million
pound
moving on to the year after
um this year looks a lot a lot better
largely because of our assumptions and
we've paired down the pay inflation
we've paired down the Energy customer
cash limited everything else and the
government grants are still included
next slide please Janet
and in terms of the longer term forecast
25 26 and 26 27 and the shortfalls begin
to increase again that's largely because
I've removed the government grants from
the budget in those years
um
we've got no assurance that they're
going to be in there so it's important
for me to do so next slide please Janet
and that's the picture that you'll see
that's in the in the mtfp that you're
going to consider later so you can see
that that position is there
um before and after council tax just as
an indication for you
next one please Janet
just wanted to spend a couple of seconds
talking about funding reforms
um as I said previously 2025 is when
that's likely to happen now there's a
commitment to reforms but there's
absolutely no certainty around the
details so it's incredibly difficult to
whole class medium term
um the intimations are that worsof
councils will get some form of
short-term support and that's known as
damping
um my view is it's proven to plan for a
smaller net budget at this stage but
there is that option that there may be
damping payments later and the next
slide demonstrates that thanks Jonah
so there you can see that's the forecast
that we've got
um and indicative damping payments make
a significant difference but it's just
we're we're very in mind all we're doing
is moving the problem out so what we're
ever doing is moving the problem with
the deficit Out Future years but
nonetheless that does help us plan the
longer we have to plan easier it is to
do it in a managed fashion
next slide please Janet and council tax
which you'll be considering today so the
government changed the referendum
principles this year from two percent to
three percent as you'll have seen from
my previous slides in the detail in the
report the external pressures of foreign
excess of that three percent so whilst
it helps it doesn't solve the short form
um and this is just me on my soapbox for
children that you know me I mentioned
this every time I speak to you the
annual increases to the base are really
important keep growing the base it makes
it so much easier to manage
foreign
moving on to the housing revenue account
so the assumptions are largely the same
as the general fund um there's an
increasing pressure on the housing
sector which I'm sure you've all read in
the news around regulation
um and written under experiencing all
the same pressures that we're
experiencing with regards to contracts
um pay inflation and the like we've gone
through The Negotiator process which is
part of the management agreement agree
the management fee and that's been built
into the mtfp that you'll have in front
of you
in terms of rents the social housing
regulator directs the landlords regards
rent increases and the consultation
there was a consultation this year in
response to embracing Rising inflation
levels so as you know it's normally CPI
plus one percent at the time of setting
in September that would have meant to
12.1 increase
so there was a national consultation and
the regulator kept the rents at 7 the 23
24 as a result
you'll all know that rents are the main
source of income ever since
self-financing in 2012 the rent's the
main source have helped the HRA stay at
a break-even position which it has to do
we have to budget for a break-even
position with you
so in terms of breaking even between 24
a minimum rent increase of four percent
was needed
um I did quite a lot of modeling around
this and anything lower than four
percent would mean that it would we
would have to be taking money out of the
reserves just to fund the in-ear budget
that makes me nervous it doesn't give
you any long-term um
resilience sorry
so it also doesn't rely for much of a
contingency or much resilience around
the um HRA which of course just like the
general funds quite volatile at the
moment we've got no certainty around
Energy prices we don't know what the pay
award is going to be and particularly
for the building trade the contracts are
very high
so I thought it was prudent to recommend
to cabinet that um some resilience
should be built in and a range of
options were presented to cabinet right
through from zero through to seven
percent which was the the cap and five
percent has been recommended on the
basis of providing some Financial
resilience to the HRA next slide please
Jano
to give me some comfort rather than
anybody else but I thought I'd share
this side since I got the data that's a
benchmark of other local authorities on
what they're actually charging in terms
of their rents so you can see where
we're in that five percent that's the
recommendation in this report
thanks Janet
just last slide quick slide on capital
investment program
um I think you'll all know these these
projects are the big ones that are going
on so in terms of the general fund we've
got Clay Cross active we've got the Town
Center work and we've got a big Vector
replacement project in the plan and in
terms of the HRA we've got Capital Works
to the housing stock further investment
in ewi and we've got the white lease
Housing Development
and I'm more than happy to go and sit
down and take any of the questions that
you might have thank you
are there any questions
Council shipment
thank you chair um on the um you talked
about some options report to Cabinet
about the proposing commission housing
vote can you tell us what those options
were and what they entailed in terms of
if you let's say zero what was the
um knock on effect
I haven't got all the details with me to
hand but what I can say is I'm producer
see but I produced a report to cabinet
that outlined what the costs were from
that point so it works on about 120 it
was about it's about 400 pounds 400 000
per cent to give you an idea so every
percent that you drop you're looking at
about 400 000 of the engineering
any other questions
no thank you Jane
moving on the next part of this
um
would now like the portfolio holding
councilor Jeremy Kenyon to speak on the
first part of the report the general
fund the HRA recommendations will be
dealt with later under a separate motion
that was right is that the 23 okay there
uh thank you chair uh thank you Jane for
the presentation and thank you for the
various briefings you've held with
groups and with the audit committee
um I hope any technical matters have now
been addressed but if something comes up
in the debate we still might call upon
you
um we're going to talk about the council
tax now and then do the the rent later
uh first thing to say is that our
council is in a strong position
financially in spite of the huge blows
of covid and the energy crisis and high
inflation and unlike some around the
country we have got a balanced project
for 23 24 and we're not having to make
big cuts and they're able to continue
providing that excellent services for
our residents
and this is partly the result of work
going back over a decade by previous
administrations and more recently
because this Administration has also
taking the necessary steps to maintain
that Financial strength and behind that
is all the excellent work done by our
offices
in seeking out efficiencies bringing in
external funding applying commercial
approaches where appropriate and
especially to the financial team who
over the years have ensured the councils
of all political Persuasions are given
the right information and guidance to
maintain that Financial strength
one particularly pleasing thing has been
the decisions in the last three years to
invest heavily in Energy Efficiency
everything from reducing our office
space footprint to now having some of
the most energy efficient and greenest
Leisure centers in the country so that
unlike many other areas we are keeping
our swimming pools open and we're
enhancing our fitness and Leisure
facilities with the huge benefits to
Residents Health social lives and even
for example children of safety due to
swimming lessons
however inflation is obviously very high
as we've already heard and with the
council wage Bill Rising about seven
percent of the supplies over 10 building
works up 30 and obviously energy 200
percent and they're both
um we've got um a difficult uh situation
so given that context we're proposing a
council tax rise of 2.99
massively under inflation so effectively
it's a it is a funding cut
um for many years
um so for many years this council's
financial Prudence means that we've not
needed to use our reserves having worked
hard to find the efficiencies needed
before that came about but in line with
government advice and in response to
both the severity and the suddenness of
the external pressures we face this is
finally the time that we need to use
some of those reserves and this will
allow us to prevent sudden drastic
services in 2324 and plan for the future
in a managed fashion so the budget does
include using 800
000 pounds of reserves for the next
financial year built there is of course
work on going to try to reduce that that
bit
uh the mtfp does not include using
reserves after that year and the
expectation is that inflation will ease
and an ongoing program of cost
production will allow a balanced budget
in the 24 25 year also
and after that the mtfp which we've got
to remember it's a long range forecast
and not really a budget after that it
does show deficits as Jane showed in the
presentation
um and the government funding is indeed
an uncertainty as it probably has been
every year that I've sat through a
finance debate in this Council which is
not many years compared to as we were
hearing earlier and but those potential
deficits are well within what could be
addressed on that time scale if need be
and it will be wrong to jump the gun and
cut Millions from the budget today
so I now move the recommendations one to
seven dealing with the general fund
thank you councilor down
thank you Jack uh I'll second and
reserve the right to speak major if
required thank you
I can now open the floor for other
members to speak you have a maximum of
five minutes to get your points across
and I'll ask you at this stage to focus
solely on the general fund issues
councilor Barker thank you
thank you chair and again thank you to
Jane and our team for for the hard work
and I know we've had some briefings on
this and the audit committee so we are
thinking uh up to speed on all this but
I don't find it a bit ironic to be
honest that uh I know if you can
remember back in 2019
when the the party that's proposing this
increased was saying that they were good
at financial management and they would
freeze the council tax and keep it down
low as it turns out it's not just the
conservative government that's put taxes
up to these record levels and also not
to mention the highest inflation in
decades and the worst performing economy
in the G7 and also the cost of living
crisis the 30 many of us in Northeast
Derbyshire
you froze the council tax for a year
during the three years since during your
term as leader I think councilor Dale
the council tax has gone up more than it
did during the four years when when
laboring control
I'm sure you're putting this record
straight in your election leaflets and
and I'm sure you'll report that back to
the electorate in Spring
moving on to the budget itself I think
it is a worry as we've said in in other
meetings Jane
next year you plan on using reserves I
think it's just been said 800 000 to
balance the vote which like everyone
knows you can only spend your savings
wounds and any policy that relies on
this is on a road to nowhere
the other figures that stand out in the
report are the sheer scale of the
savings they've got to be made in future
years we're talking over one and a half
million by 26 27 that's on top of all
the savings we've been making over the
last 10 years
and it's fair to say that to achieve
these sorts of savings from our choices
will have to be made and some skilled
political and managerial leadership will
have to be taken
that brings me on to my other point
while I should have the utmost respect
for counselor Kenyon the fact that he
has got to point that you have not
appointed a new portfolio for finance is
deeply worried given the state of these
predictions
that is the rub of it this year's
government Finance settlement as we've
just seen has been
came squarely kicking things into the
long grass putting off the sheer scale
of the financial problems facing local
government until after the next general
election in the knowledge that the labor
government will have to pick up the
pieces even the scale of this financial
crisis it will be irresponsible for any
opposition party to sabotage the Council
budget just as an act of political Point
scoring that's not how I or or our group
will act
but it's only right that your group
owned this large tax rise and that
you'll take your stewardship of this
Council finances and the decision you
are taking today to the electorate of
Northeast Derbyshire it is therefore my
intention to abstain and I will
encourage the group to do the same
thank you thank you any other speak
I agree with pretty much I've been um
Council Bach has just said there I think
the position that the council's in and
what councils are being putting today is
an uncomfortable one
um I do disagree with councilor Barkin
that is I'm not going to abstain because
I truly believe you've relaxed something
or you don't and this for me and our
counselors this is unpalatable we're
being asked to make decisions which for
years
um Council Dale and the other rest of
the leadership team have been they know
how to manage the council's finance as
they know what they're doing they can
take different hard political decisions
or what hard political decisions have
been taken in these last year or two
everything just keeps going kicks into
long grass we haven't had a couple of
members of Finance for a few months now
councilor kenyan's being dropped in all
right the the Director of Finance is
left holding the baby on their budget
because I've not seen any political
decisions which have directed this
budget whatsoever
Rick knows it haven't even been
approached to come up with various
options to save money instead of putting
up that rent inside a meeting with them
this week and they have confirmed this
which is why I questioned you about the
options put to cabinet
speak to retinol directors they're
telling me one thing you're telling me
another I think some some we can't I
can't vote for this I really can't vote
for this the various things within the
budget itself which are raised or in the
audit committee meetings planning the
appeals doesn't have any cash in it
we're going to keep dragging money out
of the bottomless pit in the reserves
every time we've got planning appeals
coming in there's no money in District
cancellations as we've seen we've had
conservative members resigning and going
off the council in their droves in the
last four years so how can we have zero
in assuming we can have no violations in
between
the Charlie Park Cafe numbers on the
budget
reckons we're going to end up with a
quarter of a million income there's no
there's no Cafe in any Leisure Center
that's going to make quarter of a
million pound income and yet we think we
are because because it's Charlie Parker
it's a brand new building it's insane
and the killer martial article Center
cost we were told in this chamber that
would be breaking even it would not be
costing this Council hundreds of
thousands of pounds what are we at a
year or two later it's costing the
council hundreds of thousands of pounds
and that figures just keeps going up if
you look at the projections that is not
what councilors in this chain will be
told at the time when that proposal was
going through
um and then like I say I wish I could
vote for it and you know we have to take
these harsh decisions but I cannot bring
myself to vote for increasing rents from
the most vulnerable in Northeast
dermshire and banging the tax law to the
maximum according to the projections um
the Director of Finance has just put up
so the maximum for the next however many
is five years
how how can we be we'll be forced to do
that and I actually think that members
should have been engaged a lot sooner
than we were than January of this year
because we might have been able to
actually help and come up with a
consensus on what sort of decisions we
take going forward unfortunately that's
not happened unfortunately I'll be
voting against this would you today
thank you just a reminder that this is
just a section on the general fund and
nothing else at this point is there
anyone else anything to say
councilor for now
hear that
yeah
oh well first of all I'd like to thank
Jane and her team who've obviously
working really hard to make the numbers
come together in a difficult budget
period uh pressures from labor material
costs and the energy demand which
couldn't be predicted have made it even
more complicated
and we all know that the council is
facing lots of challenges in the future
this year I have with with the budget
that for me there shouldn't see any
proposals on how we're going to try and
improve efficiency or how we're going to
reduce costs at some stage those
decisions have got to be made if we're
going to balance the books
the second item for myself pretty
important is business growth
there's no real forecast that business
growth and revenue increases will be
delivered for business it's a fairly
static budget going forward over the
next few years
it's also have a reliant on damping
payments which are fictitious numbers
we're not sure what's going to happen
there they may be hired it may be lower
but they're included in the budget in
future years
there's nothing as I can see and I'll
waffle it a bit now on the effects of
Northwood
um that's the contract that's the
project it's been looked at it's been
reviewed I don't know whether that's the
positive or A negative for the council
another area that concerns me is the
amount thousands of pounds that
potentially being spent
on frivolous planning Appeals
not sure where that fits in the budget
I'm not sure what the numbers are but it
seems to be a lot of money being spent
on something that we've been advised not
to do
the other area that probably came to
light this morning is the Leisure Center
and I think the leaders mentioned this I
think they're a good thing for the
district the promoting healthy and
well-being but they are coming at a cost
and I think the projections in the
budget are fairly optimistic and a
general review of the Leisure centers
will need to take place to see what they
really are costing the investment and
the returns
particularly when the Queen's Park uh
Sports Center is looking to close his
path
so if they can't generate profit they're
interested to see how the other Leisure
centers in our district could do better
which leads me down to the two areas I
want to go concentrate on the two the
council rate at 2.99 we need to do that
it's below what the recommendation is
but we've somehow got to balance the
books if we can
but the bigger thing for me is the
drawing down resilience fund something
like three quarters of a million
has been put into the pot to balance the
Box
I've never set a budget with a million
pound backup to balance it
that's not sustainable going forward
but there's no proposals in this
document to say how we can impact on
that going forward
realize you need to do it this year
but it's not sustainable going forward
and for that reason I won't be voting
for the budget thank you thank you
councilor down do you wish to respond
yeah thank you Janet there's quite a lot
of politics in that so I'm going to try
and answer there's lots of different
points I'll try and answer as best as I
can but it might seem a little bit
sporadic I suppose
um I suppose the first thing I'd say is
that certain council tax is always a
difficult and delicate balance to strike
we've got to manage the impact on our
residents as well as the very
significant pressures uh that we're
facing as a council and those services
that our residents rely upon and I think
we've got to have that very firmly in
mind when we reach a decision and for me
you know the point I've come back to at
every stage is that 2.99 is well below
inflation in essence this is a real
terms cut to the book yeah so it's not a
debate about how much we're increasing
council tax this is about a debate about
how much of a cut to our budget we're
absorbing in order to mitigate the
impact on our residence and that's the
absolute reality I think it's also worth
highlighting the actual value of our our
proportion of council tax attacks and
what the increase actually means we're
looking at about uh given the fact that
our proportion of council tax is only a
very thin sliver it's about it's it's
less than a quarter of the total council
tax bill so for a bandee property we're
looking at an increase of about six
pound per year that's it's it's a very
very low increase in the grand scheme of
things we're always worth reminding
ourselves of that virtually no other
country other counts in the country are
going to be arguing for less of an
increase than three percent
just on the points on the resilience
Reserve I think it's really important to
just set out that is a specific reserve
for resilience it's set up for exactly
this purpose it's rainy day money and
it's worth highlighting it's a
completely different Reserve uh to the
to the investor save reserve and the
general Reserve so it's an extra reserve
and actually it's I think it's a good
thing that as a council we've set that
Reserve up and put two million pounds
into it for these exact scenarios we
always knew covered was going to be
difficult and you know it's quite likely
we always knew it would be difficulties
after covid so that Reserve is is there
for exactly that purpose and to mitigate
the impact as councilor Kenyon said it
would be absolutely foolish of us to
start slashing Services left right and
Center when we know that inflation is
going to come down it's far better to
use that Reserve that we've purposely
built up for this purpose to have a
smoother Landing through a more
efficient and and better run Council
longer term
um I think we have to remember that this
affects the base
um you know failure to a set an
appropriate level council tax now will
affect us for every single year
thereafter there's been a few points
around who the portfolio holder for
budget is I thought it was pretty clear
it's councilor Kenyan he sat there
giving the introducing the the paper and
introducing the Motions he's done a huge
amount of work and I'm very grateful for
councilor Kenyan to do that but the
reality is that
um setting the budget is not the
responsibility of cabinets responsible
with every single counselor in this room
and I think we all have to be really
clear about what it means to have stain
on a boat like this for me it is an
absolute abdication of responsibility
and we hear councilor Barker talking
about picking up the pieces uh after a
conservative administrator just reminded
him what happened when labor left office
in 2010 then the note that was left that
said that there was no money left
um just on written all directors
councilor Shipman raised the point
around them just just like to reassure
him that they were there at the informal
cabinet meeting where this issue was
discussed and I remember myself even
asking for their opinion on it so I
don't know what you've been told or
whether it's uh you know been been
slightly warped in your own imagination
or what but certainly they were there
and they were they were part of that
discussion and I very much took on board
their feedback
um there's been discussion around the
sports centers and what they what
they're costing us we as an
Administration back our sports centers
to the hill we're investing massively in
them we recognize they're a massive good
for our communities they positively
impact hugely in terms of the health and
well-being of our of our residents they
are clearly going to be impacted by
inflation more so than most other parts
of the council because they are very
buildings based in the buildings that do
use up a lot of energy so we have to
accept that there's going to be a bit of
a hit this year but from my perspective
we absolutely back them and actually the
Cafe infrastructure that we have we you
know that's a key part of our campaign
to get them to wash their own face and
to reduce costs they are a commercial
asset to those buildings and I know in
dronfield it's a key part of the
strategy that means that drumfield turns
a small Surplus rather than deficit yes
um on planning appeals I believe
personally that we're a planning
committee makes a decision to oppose an
application we need to back that so all
of this talk about wiping off you know
just drawing a line on the planning
appeals I think it's quite disappointing
really it's it's not really what
residents expect from a democratic
Council that we're going to run away as
soon as the costs get a little bit scary
I think when residents make a case and
the planning committee refuses an
application we should back that up it's
absolutely really vital for public trust
in local councils that we do that
just on council tax I think we have kept
it low uh I averaged that it's less than
two percent a year for the past four
years you know we've faced a difficult
challenge with covid with inflation with
other issues and I think we have kept it
broadly low or certainly as low as we
possibly can whilst delivering really
good service
and we've also championed transformation
savings throughout the first four years
we've done a heck of a lot of savings
and we'll continue to do that the the uh
the budget position in three or four
years time doesn't particularly daunt me
I know as an organization we are
fantastic at being resilient and
adapting to the challenges that come
before us and we have an excellent
senior management team to deliver that
and a very strong Administration that
can deliver that as well so I'm happy to
Second as I say and absolutely refute
most of the points that have been made
by the opposition and disappointed it's
been turned so political Jack
thank you
I've got two hands up councilor Hancock
then councilor Barry
thank you chair
um yes to pick up on on several of the
points a lot of them I'm actually going
to harp on Plus for years I've said
exactly the same as councilor for now we
can't keep sitting there saying that
there's unidentified savings going up we
actually need to have somebody talk
about us and I said this under both
having illustrations
um so the previous one to be fair to
them actually weren't as bad at saying
though there was a number of ones but
um I'm a bit older than cows of the day
and I remember the labor government to
the end of the 70s which asks this
country in a real mess as well so I
don't think they can grow on in terms of
that
um I will pick up on what counts the
Dale said there obviously there's a
clear disparity and I know we're not on
the HRA yet but uh the directors of
rignal that's just said to us
that they hadn't even been asked to
present Alternatives so there's clearly
a discussion that needs to be had
between them and the cabinet somewhere
um obviously
we're playing with words that was a
resilient Reserve because ultimately we
are throwing reserves into this to make
it a balanced budget and
it's very dubious when we're starting to
call it balanced budget when we're
having to use reserves to actually make
his balance so that is a concern it's
not sustainable
um in terms of the um in terms of the
planning yes we should where we have got
a robust case to defend a planning a
planning decision we should do so I
think the the key Point that's learned
from our perspective is that we need to
be putting money back in there
um it isn't a bottomless pit and as we
have more and more cases which we're
going to defend then that Reserve is
going to go down as well so somewhere
along the line it needs a topping back
up again so that there has to be some
sort of budgetary aspect to their
um some of these figures which people
have said they are concerning yes
whenever you're proposing a budget it's
difficult but we have got some figures
which quite clearly are meant to make it
look a better position than it is
um and obviously we're all well aware of
what's happened in Chesterfield
um being smart Leisure Center earlier on
um if they can't make you balance we've
got no chance
um in areas that are typical less
afterwards I know drumfield is kind of
the exception when you compare it with
kilometers I can come and play cross so
I think um there are concerns there
um 299 yes it is alone
um it sounded below inflation but
obviously all of our residents are being
impact by the inflationary increase
there's an addition 299 is hurting them
no matter how how insignificant it may
seem in the grand scheme of things
um
but we're voting against the budget
because it simply doesn't make sense
there are anomalies in it which we can't
reconcile and on that basis we can't
approve this budget and so that's where
we sit on that one thank you
Council Barrow
just
you might be pleased to know this isn't
about your figures and your budget oh
hold on I just want to say I'm I am
absolutely appalled by some of the
language that you use from the Tory
party
why would you say that somebody's got a
warped mind
you're always coming up and do you do
deriding people you can't speak to us
without trying to pull us down and it's
about time it's stopped you're not the
first and you can laugh as much as you
want counselor Dale you're really
beginning to get on my nerves with this
along with your your members over there
that did the same last year where the
complaint went in about your behaviors
you're not improving and I'm getting a
little bit Fed Up of it now so if we
can't be civil to one another keep your
mouth closed thank you
are there any other comments concerns
councilor Canyon you have a right to
reply so thank you
thank you
um a lot of uh a lot of the points have
already been responded to by councilor
Dale
um uh in particular just to re-emphasize
three 2.99 Rises around a five percent
cut that's a massive thing to deliver
for the council already
um in terms of cost cutting
I don't think there's too many things to
list to be honest energy use is one
um all the other work done on our
Leisure centers is part of it
um what we're doing is combining offices
it's all about cost reductions uh better
use of Technology that's going on in all
the various Services again to reduce
running costs uh Team restructuring
where appropriate that's another area
where there's a lot of work being done
to reduce costs and uh undoubtedly
there's that work on procurement as well
trying to in a very difficult
environment make sure that we do get the
best best price for the things that we
buy so you know there's an endless list
of things being done there's no
particular big thing though but coming
to Leisure I suppose you could say
um close all the Leisure centers yeah
that would save a load of money for sure
however first of all I would put our
Leisure team up against any in the
country any Council Leisure team they
are very good at running a service and
they can make cafes work work and they
do make them work and they actually help
to cross subsidize the rest of the
service and uh yeah it might be an
option for for a different
Administration to kind of say this one
will not consider that because the use
of leisure centers is is rising their
importance is rising they are absolutely
a key Community Asset and we will
continue to support them and we will
ensure as we've done with killer moth
that we're a facility is in grave danger
of running uh into the ground and being
closed because of years of
mismanagement we will step in and make
sure that facility survives and it
thrives for the sake of the residence
which is exactly what we've done and
we've done it even in spite of the covid
and the energy crisis pressures uh in
terms of the reserves it's a one-year
hit
starting a war in in Europe and throwing
uh NG prices through the roof that's uh
that's one of the few times when using
reserves does make sense
um just on damping payments Council for
now uh yes you're right in the sense
that
um and as Jane would back up we cannot
depend on those however I think it
probably if you look back through budget
papers for a very long time it's a very
similar story there's always the unknown
in the future and while you don't
necessarily take action immediately
about the biggest unknowns you do
um look at them understand them and be
ready for them if that should happen and
it will be a very important not to
however would it be equally imprudent to
cut things now on the basis of what may
be in three years time so I think every
Administration when they put in that
position comes to the same conclusion
and because we have two years of
certainty that's
um that's plenty of Landing room if the
government did announce A Five-Year Plan
to reduce funding in some drastic way I
guess uh difficult choices and uh not
really part of political choice there's
just facts of how local government is is
funded and has been funded for a long
time
so
um was there any other things to comment
on I think I'll leave it so I just say
yes on business growth I I do take the
point uh this morning I'd say to the
morning I was in drum field at a startup
event hosted by Northeast Derbyshire
District Council and where we were
specifically trying to encourage new
businesses into the area a new business
startups it's not a direct Remy to the
council alone it's shared with a lot of
other organizations and I can assure you
that in Northeast Derbyshire we are well
perceived by those organizations like
the um British business bank and so on
um but yeah there's an awful lot of work
to do to build up business in Northeast
Derbyshire and in Derbyshire and in the
East Midlands and I could hear councilor
Lewis in his head what he'll be saying
now about the investment from the
government which I'll leave that one for
another day so I'll move the
recommendations one to seven thank you
chair thank you
we will now move to the vote we've had
the motion before us it's been moved and
seconded and the monitor officer will
now conduct the vote which will be a
recorded vote
thank you I'll read your names out in
reverse order as usual can you please
tell me if I'm voting for against or
abstaining
counselor P Wright
councilor B Wright
councilor Welton
that was a Thacker
that's the Tate
Council Stratford Stevenson
Council Shipman against Council rough
that's a rouse
that's a row
that's a renick
answer reader
abstain
answer pal
that's the pots
outside
Pickering
councilor Morley
Elsa Lily
I'm staying
that's a ligate
outside Lewis
Council Lacy
Elsa Kerry
councilor Kenyon councilor Jones
councilor Hutchinson
that's the hearts Hall
so answer Hancock again councilor Hall
that's legit
Elsa for now
counselor M Foster
that's like a foster
councilor Emmons
Council Elliot
Elsa drabble
that's a dating
that's a Dale oh that's a cupid or
Council Cornwall
that's the Cooper
Council Bluff
outside Birkin
councilor Barker sorry Council Barry
Council Barker abstain
councilor Armitage oh
foreign
the results are as follows the role
result was 26 4. five against and 14
abstentions the motion has been carried
this leads us on to the housing revenue
account I am the other rhl board members
are declared kindly interests so in this
we intend to leave the meeting during
the discussion and the vote however
before we can do that I have a motion
for a temperature for the remainder of
this item
I'd like to recommend councilor Barry
to replace me for this
oh councilor Barry Lewis sorry I'm
looking at him half asleep here
I need to go home
thank you he's got the right names
are those in favor
wonderful
those against
extensions
Council Barry Lewis here you go
grateful the council to leave the room
in the meantime I'll thank you for your
overwhelming support and support of my
temper chair of this uh spot in the
meeting
uh so there we're dealing with uh the
HRA part of the uh agenda which is items
nine well which is I it which is
um sections 9 to 15 and the
recommendations of your report so I'm
guessing that we just throw it over I'm
a grateful
councilor came in to speak first
yes thank you thank you chair so moving
on to council rents uh the government
have set a seven percent limit that's
already I don't know three percent or so
below inflation however we are proposing
only a five percent increase uh section
151 officers has informed us that the
HRA is required to budget so that it
breaks even each year and going below
five percent will present a serious risk
for that due to the huge number of
unknowns
in the last few years we have invested
the rental income and millions of pounds
of government grants in Energy
Efficiency work our tenants are now
benefiting from that work in every
Energy bill both reducing fuel poverty
and ensuring there is more money spent
in our local economy
so please bear in mind that every one
percent we do not increase rent by
that's like translates into losing 1.6
million pounds of investment over an
Administration
it's always a balance between the short
and long term so the five percent rise
reflects the belief that it will be a
huge disservice to council house tenants
to reduce our investment in the fabric
of our Council houses and that would
lead them to incur much greater costs in
higher energy bills it would also reduce
the total number of council houses for
example by reducing our ability to
invest in projects such as wide lease
and uh just as with the council tax it
should be noted that rent Rises are
limited by a percentage each year so any
rise not taken is then a cut for every
year going forward so the the problem
accumulates over time
our Council house rents are well under
the target of eight percent of private
sector rents indeed in some areas
they're more like 30 below the market
rent
and alongside uh so
both Council and writtenald are also
facing increasing demands on our
services and the social housing
regulator for example is putting in
additional requirements in relation to
damp and mold handling and as a landlord
we can take comfort through a better
place than many others as a result of
the work and the proactive work that
rignal have done and continue to do to
ensure our attendance homes are safe but
these extra measures do inevitably add
some additional cost
and of course Rick nod are experiencing
similar cost pressures as a result of
high inflation and I'm not quite sure
where the idea that they've not worked
on any efficiencies comes from because
we've been very clearly told that they
have made a lot of done a lot of work to
ensure that the rise in the management
fee is only eight hundred thousand
pounds instead of a one and a half
million pounds and it should also be
remembered that's the first rise in many
years the management fee has been frozen
for a long time so they've been working
on efficiencies a long time and they
continue to do so
it's also just important to note uh the
thief paid from the HRA which is funded
from Council house rents and this does
not affect the council tax
um
what else uh
one more thing
um
well as I've already said really and
it's been said before the rents are used
to operate our Council houses and to
invest in upgrading them and we hear
continual complaints about the quality
of rental stock around the country and
uh we we can't afford to let that stock
deteriorate for the sake of our
attendance and residents and in
particular large amount of the capital
program is used to increase levels of
insulation as I mentioned earlier and
and the other improvements that our
tenants rightly expect to have uh houses
that meet the lessable standards and are
fit for purpose
so over the life of this plan
um 81 million pounds is broadcast to be
spent on our housing stock obviously
some of that is the new kitchens in
houses that have been uh 25 years
without because of uh whatever it will
be uh
um whatever uh comes down the pipe
really
um
but it's all about investing for the
future so put simply the choices between
suitable affordable Council housing or
taking a very short-term view that will
hinder residents for well decades to
come so I'll move the rest of the
recommendations in the report thank you
chair
thank you counselor Kenyon
councilor Dale second and reserve the
right to reply to you thank you thank
you very much and we have councilor
balka thank you Chad am I on Lovely uh I
think he's fair to say this was very
difficult one indeed for me yeah and
yeah
we don't mind they have left the
building
I've been so focused on my papers not
looking at what's going on behind me
thank you
yeah yeah can I carry on thank you yeah
it is a difficult one this because uh as
you can imagine personally it's very
difficult and for our group because uh I
fully understand the argument that's
been fought forward we want to spend
money on uh on tackling the
non-traditional housing and all the work
that needs doing I understand there's
extra pressures now with the damn
situation that we've got by uh the
government saying we've got to uh we do
something about that
uh we also understand that there's a
shortage a council houses that that we
could do more and build more Council
houses but this is the ball we all
understand the five percent increase on
the rents at this point when all the
other council tax bills are going to go
up not just North East but everywhere
else uh it might be uh the straw that
breaks the camel's back really and we we
don't think that can be sustainable
really so Marco said it's a very very
difficult decision we need to balance
the books we need to tackle the issues
of the housing sector we've got all that
but we feel at this time we don't think
we can support this uh this rent
increase
so as you've said it Alex it's he's
probably uh
we have to make a decision and the
decision is
we're not going to support the rent
decrease
thank you councilor Barker councilor
Hancock
thank you chair um a couple of important
points um in terms of this
no um and just to actually correct
councilor Kenya and no one said that um
rignal hadn't made efficiencies they
haven't been asked to look at
alternative costings together put you
through that slightly different things
what was that
um I think one important factor to
actually keep their services exactly as
they are and to do the investment that
they are doing only needs a four percent
increase
I think that that is one key thing for
five percent is being suggested as a
buffer an additional contingency it
isn't actually needed to balance that
budget and I think that and yeah it
might only be one percent but that one
percent given that a lot of our our
Council house tenants awesome of our
most vulnerable people in the in the
whole District that one percent to us
makes a huge difference and I think it
will to a lot of them
um I think whilst we've picked upon on
new things which are actually being
forced on written of like the dampen
mold situation
we also need to take to acknowledge how
much they pick up of stuff that actually
isn't theirs and because of government
Cuts in Social care and the police
they're actually dealing with a heck of
a lot more anti-social behavior issues
than they should be and they're also
becoming the first point of contact when
people are using social care and support
and benefits advice and there's a lot of
money and time that is being invested
from Rick Nails in services that
actually they shouldn't even be
delivering but is that it's Testament to
them that they are picking up picking up
that slack and also that is coming out
of the the HRA obviously to pay for
those roles as well so again we can't
support five percent one yes four
percent might understand nominal but it
is doable it is doable for the council
without it having an impact on services
and and obviously that extra little bit
of money in people's pockets would make
it a big difference during the cost of
living crisis
thank you councilor Hancock I'm slow
down yeah
uh can you hear me okay thank you um I
think it's just worth reiterating the
slide that Jane put up which
demonstrates we are one of the lowest
already uh out of about 35 I think that
were uh because sort of giving a straw
poll at a recent meeting that we
attended uh who are going as low as five
percent
I think it's cancel Hancock's point you
know it is a fair point that four
percent is is survivable but the first
uh rule about setting a budget is always
to allow for contingency we don't know
what's going to happen over the course
of a year so I think an additional one
percent uh clearly obviously it will
always have an impact on residents and
absolutely accept that um you know this
again is a difficult balance between
balancing the needs of the council the
needs of our housing stock with the uh
the needs of our residents who are
facing difficult uh Financial challenges
but I think that having that contingency
is really important and certainly in
discussions that we've had uh with them
on with the uh section 151 officer as
well
um you know it would be very very tight
without setting that uh that additional
contingency and could make life very
difficult for us and could forces uh to
make cuts to some services that we
wouldn't want to deal with I think on
the application behavior issues I would
disagree somewhat and say that Rickman
should always have a role uh in
community safety and dealing with and
social behavior there are major housing
provider it's part of what they get the
management fee for and I think they do a
very very good job of it they've got a
lot to give and a lot to contribute to
that discussion and that work around
ensuring that people feel safe in their
in their community so I I would disagree
and say that they you know that's an
important part of the role absolutely
accept that you know a lot of people are
are struggling at the moment but I think
the other thing that we do have to
remember is that that
um quite a large proportion of council
housing tenants that do get some support
under means tested welfare system and I
think the thing that really sticks in my
mind is that there will be some people
in Council housing who don't uh don't uh
they don't qualify for means tested
benefits so they do pay their rent in
full and they'll be very comparable
people to them in the private rented
sector who are already paying a heck of
a lot more in rents anyway and will be
faced with much higher increases in
their bills and I think if I was in that
situation I'd be pretty upset and
annoyed if the council were reducing uh
the rent Rises on those in Council
housing because effectively that will
feel like an account is subsidizing the
bills of those people and I think we do
have to pick that broader balanced uh
Viewpoint in that context into
a fair figure and really importantly it
enables us to continue to invest in
Council housing so that the better
housing for our residents A Greener
warmer homes for our residents and also
that they help to reduce the energy
bills of our residents as well so I
think five percent is the right figure
um it's a difficult decision as everyone
else has highlighted construction
inflation at the minute is 20 to 30
percent uh and you know we want to keep
doing that investment so I think uh from
from my perspective that additional one
percent to get us to five percent is the
right decision uh for this Council take
a chance
thank you very much indeed I'll use my
uh
position at the church to make one point
reinforce what councilor Dale has said
around
um private sector rents and not
forgetting of course there's an awful
lot of mortgage payers out there
over the course of the last year or so
I've seen some pretty significant Rises
as well to their mortgage payment
um and yeah makes a very good point as
well around the initiatives around green
investment into our Council housing that
is incredibly important to keep down
people's bills and it's something that
we clearly cannot stop doing I think is
a
wrong decision to to not for this
this rise in the way that has set out in
the report councilor Kenyan do you want
to make any signing up points yes
sorry I didn't see you there cancer
treatment
um I feel like I've been Twilight Zone
we've got conservative councilors trying
to persuade us about we need to vote for
this increase when it was the government
the party that you're part of is the
reason that mortgage payments are
through the roof and inflation's off the
scale
mortgage percentages has gone up from
three to six percent because of the
former prime minister's mistakes in
government and she tried to when she has
her economic reforms and now you're
trying to persuade us that we need to
vote for these increases because those
that have got higher rents now off the
back of that are somehow going to be
annoyed at the other people in Northeast
Irish who have got a reduced rate
clustering Council housing I mean is
that that literally is the most
laughable thing in the YouTuber both
said to be quite honest and that takes
them doing
um there's no way we can vote for this
I think it might be a compromise if we
could take it to four but you know at
least it's something
but just to try and convince us because
your own part has failed in government
caught local governments funding
the current Member of Parliament for
Northeast Derbyshire voted for a 15
quite only a few years ago and now
you're telling us that we all need to
back you on your crusade to increase
rents and taxes because of those
mistakes it's absolutely incredible to
be quite honest
thank you for those pointed political uh
interjections there but I've always been
Bank of England that set interest rates
uh thank you chair
so thank you chair uh yes I mean what to
say really
um uh it's obvious that the
conservatives to blame for uh for
everything including a war uh in Europe
um
so I absolutely I don't accept that I
think what we're looking at now at five
percent is is cut to the Bone I mean
four percent it's it's a round number to
be honest it could be four point two
percent four point three percent
whatever happens
um it won't be an exact number what will
end up happening is four hundred
thousand pounds a year 1.6 million
pounds per Administration will not be
available to invest in housing stock
there's not enough in the the
um the others paths with the community
services to actually cover that probably
even if you completely strip them to
zero and so the end result we're
inevitably be worse houses for residents
and I talk to Residents all the time
about the Council houses and the
installation from my interest in the
climate change actually rather than the
finance it makes a huge difference to
them and we will just be hurting
residents if we cut investment in those
programs and so
um that's why we're at five percent and
anything else will be I would assume
seen pretty badly by those uh residents
who are in a house that doesn't get
improved because there isn't the money
to do it so thank you chair
okay thank you very much indeed
um I think that was everybody
um
we have to go to the uh the vote uh now
I believe this is a recording voting him
okay
yes yes chair uh by law a recorded vote
so as before I'll leave names in reverse
order please can you tell me if you're
voting for against or are abstaining
councilor P Wright
councilor B Wright
Elsa Welton
oh
hesitate
outside Stratford Stevenson
that's a shipment
against
that's a rouse
Council row
calcic
that's a reader
against that's a Powell that supports
Council Platz
that's a Pickering
that's the Morley
that's a lily
against
that's a Liggett
answer Lewis
Council Lacy
Elsa Kerry okay Council Kenyan
Elsa Jones
Council Hutchinson
that's a heart song
that's a Hancock okay that's the hall
um
that's legit
answer for now
outside M Foster
counselor a foster
Council emin's
councilor Elliot
Council drabble
Council Dayton
Council Dale oh that's a Cupid
that's a call
that's a Cooper Council cloth
oh sorry
Council Birkin
yeah Council Barry
that's the Barker
yeah that's Armitage
thank you
so
um the result was uh 24 and 20 against
and one abstention but with the
Chairman's casting vote that makes 21
for 21 against and one extension
I believe my work here is done
um so we shall uh call in uh if we can
the uh members at work
that left the room
I'm just wondering if counselor Ruff
would be candidate after that we have
one of her mints before I leave my suit
here
in the meantime can I ask you councilor
Barry's going to jump to my defense
after I was called vapable by the
opposition am I being a bit of a
snowflake about that
he
was
okay
there we go item seven treasury strategy
reports
please listen to that and it's so that
you counselor Kenyan again
yes one of the most exciting uh reports
of the Year this um I read it
in great detail to my sleep's detriment
um yes this paper covers our borrowing
strategy investment strategy methods
strategies are to support the mtfp and
so while the paper includes the various
uh Capital requirements Etc this is
about the processes we use to manage our
money to support that mtfp rather than
the mtfpsl
the first key thing here is that there
is no new borrowing planned for 2324 and
we have reduced total borrowing by 2.2
million pounds over the last year to 147
million
it will rise slightly in future years in
cash terms to support Investments such
as Charlie Park and whitelease and the
council housing Capital Works program so
in real terms the debt could be actually
slightly lower in four years time due to
the effect of normal inflation as
opposed to the current High inflation
it's also worth noting that of that 147
million pounds borrowing the large
majority of it is from many years ago
when the council housing stock was
transferred to the council
as you would expect the aim is to make
the most efficient use of our funds
balanced against risk and in general and
in part due to regulation we take a
fairly cautious approach to investing
I'm sure we can all remember the
Icelandic Bank problems that some
organizations got themselves into
and we also have funds of various kinds
such as the HRA that fluctuate as needed
to support the capital program so when
you look at the numbers one year doesn't
really tell you much it's the whole
sequence of it and um but so what that
means is rather than having money just
sitting there earning nothing we want to
maximize return on it
um but sometimes that actually means
effectively boring using the
borrowing the money internally is better
than um
borrowing from the market so it's a
really complex picture in there to be
honest um and uh our officers manage
that on our behalf uh to optimize that
um whatever the circumstances are
uh one last thing it's just important to
note the difference between prudent and
improved and borrowing uh opinions might
differ on these things but prudent
boring will for example have a robust
business case behind it which will
always include the full cost of that
borrowing regardless of any treasury
management work that might mean less
cash is actually borrowed than needed
and we have several examples of that
such as Charlie Parker I would expect
will uh happen absolutely not quite
happen yet that's in the next year or
two and we haven't will continue to
avoid any imprudent borrowing so I move
the recommendations in the report thank
you chair
thank you do we have a second answer the
report
councilman Dale
and now for other members to speak does
anyone wish to make a comment
elsewhere Barker yeah thanks for that
jazz I think you've uh you've clarified
it for me thank you
no more
Council shipment
um I think I might be speaking for the
audit committee and I say this but I
think most of us agree on there because
the council's not doing enough
with its money
we are very safe from all the reports
and presentations we've added audit we
are Ultra safe
um and to Chromecast the fact that it
probably make more money under his bed
what we're doing with it
[Laughter]
um but yeah it's just very blunt isn't
it the plan that we haven't planned we
could be you know we're talking about
budgets being squeezed and we having to
put all rents and Council taxes I want
to go up and yeah we've got this money
sat there that we could be doing more
with to make more money with it
um and we're just simply not doing that
um but I think the the cabin need to
look at that and actually again come up
with a plan
um to do that
thank you any other comment
down would you like to register yeah
thank you thank you chair
thank you
um yes I I would say we probably are
erring on the safe side uh again I think
if you follow the news there's no end of
councils have got into difficulty with
NG company schemes
um borrowing uh money and then investing
it to try to get a higher return and
then failing miserably
um we do use that money to fund some of
the borrowing for things like the the um
um investments in Leisure centers and
things like that and I think that's a
sensible way to get a higher return on
that money it doesn't actually show up
very clearly in the figures I think but
it's uh it's a sensible way to do it and
um it was my own money personally I
would probably take a higher risk with
it when it's public money it's just not
the same option you have to be more
cautious and it's one of those it's an
easy thing to say and I do wish that we
could make more out of it but
um
yeah it's a brave person who who pushes
the boat out on that to be honest and
you increase the risk of the council in
a way that I don't think
um would be worth the the small extra
returns thank you
thank you there is the motion before us
which has been moved and second is can
we agree this by acclimation
or do you want
a local
uh
everyone all in favor please show the
hands
thank you very much that's passed
item eight review of the council's
policy under the gambling Act 2005.
this is the review of the council's
policy under the gambling act 2005 I
would like the portfolio holder
councilman Mark Foster to speak on it
over to councilor Foster thank you chair
I'm happy to present the reporting to
the review of the council's policy under
the gambling Act
but the council is responsible for the
regulation of gambling licenses under
the gambling act 2005 as part of those
responsibilities the council is required
to renew and publish a new policy every
three years his standard practice to
also publish a local area profile with
the policy in 2018 the council's policy
and local area profile under an
extensive review to ensure that they
were consistent with national guidance
and as a result were published in 2019
in 2022 the Environmental Health Service
conducted a review of the policy and the
local area profile and identified some
minor changes that needed to be made
those changes included objects to the
references to National guidance and
updates to the local demographic
information uh that was population
statistics and a current license numbers
largely the revised policy and local
library profile were approved by the
licensing committee and the public
consultation was carried out over 12
weeks
the responses them of that consultation
were then considered by the committee
and final versions of the policy and lab
were approved with a recommendations
Council that they'd be adopted by an
office has been instructed to follow
this statutory process for adoption I'm
happy to move chair the recommendations
on page 88. thank you thank you do we
have a second it's absolutely good thank
you
I'll now open the floor to members who
wish to speak or make comment
s
the motion has been moved and seconded
are we happy to agree this via
acclimation
let's have a quick show of hands anybody
happy
thank you
item 11 is motions
just to confirm that we have no
questions that either the public or
members so go straight to item 11 which
is emotions we only have one today which
has been marked on your agenda as motion
a this motion has been moved by
councilor Barker who I think would now
like to update us on this councilor
Barker yeah thank you yeah yeah thanks
for that right yeah I'd uh wish to
withdraw this motion thank you
thank you
very simple
ice and 12th the end of the meeting
so this the motion has been withdrawn so
that leads straight onto urgent business
which there isn't any so I now declare
the meeting over thank you all for your
attendance
and I hope to see some of you on Sunday
take care